Hello everybody. Welcome to another holistic health hour. This is Dr Kevin Connors and we have some questions to go over. So let's jump right into it. I want to welcome any new members. So this is for multiple courses. So we have multiple different questions.
So understand that our clinic we have got the glory for everything. So let's just jump into some questions.
How is autoimmune disease diagnosed? So a lot of people think that they might have an autoimmune disease. They have been diagnosed with an autoimmune disease.
Most of the time it's the other way around, they don't think that they have autoimmune disease and they do have an autoimmune disease and it's never been diagnosed. That's the other way around.
But that's usually the real scenario that's taking place. The truth is that just about everybody in a short period of time are going to be dealing with an autoimmune disease.
I would say that because we live in such a toxic world that toxins are the number one thing biotoxins as well.
Getting at our system crossing damaged barriers, gut barriers, lung barriers, skin barriers, toxins that our ancestors were never exposed to.
It means that people are ejecting into their arm. We're letting somebody inject into their arm in the guys that it's actually protecting them that's causing their body to create antibodies to self tissue.
However, your immune system has one thing that it's meant to do only one thing that is kill things. So your immune system is only created to kill biotoxins, a pathogen, an enemy, a virus, a bacteria, some fungus that's in your body.
But when we have this over abundance of toxins in our body that is overwhelmed in our liver detoxification pathways and then being shunted out of the blood into the extracellular spaces.
And for into the cells, a cytoplasm, your immune system will attempt to kill it, can't kill it, over and over again, can end up firing a B cell reaction and create antibodies against the neighboring tissue to the toxin.
So that is a major reason, one major reason why we have autoimmune disorders and definition of an autoimmune diseases that you have antibodies to self tissue.
And then you could go into my videos on autoimmune diseases that different phases of autoimmune disease. You can have a latent phase, you can have a reactive phase.
So go into that video to understand that.
Long answer for a short question. An autoimmune disease is diagnosed based upon the showing person showing positive tissue antibodies.
And then you go into the different phases of an autoimmune disease. And then when you're in that third phase, that very reactive autoimmune phase where you're really getting systems and tissue destruction.
And that's when, so there's some gray area in the diagnosis. So if I do a thyroid panel and I show TPO antibodies, but I just do a thyroid panel as a screen, I don't have any thyroid symptoms whatsoever.
And so therefore, you're not going to see tissue destruction of the thyroid. But if I have no thyroid symptoms whatsoever, I might have elevated TPO antibodies.
So technically, I may have poshimoto's, but the doctor may not give you a diagnosis poshimoto's if you showed all signs of, you know, low or high thyroid issues, the graves at the time.
But so an autoimmune disease is diagnosed by a blood test showing positive tissue antibodies.
But then that's the technical diagnosis, but then the clinical diagnosis is when those are accompanied by symptoms and or worst case scenario symptoms and tissue destruction.
So that's how an autoimmune disease is diagnosed. My son has Lyme. How can I help navigate this journey? That's pretty deep question.
Because it really depends on what phase of Lyme there is. So if you're in the acute phase, I'm sure you're talking about chronic phase Lyme here.
Not in acute phase Lyme, but in a chronic phase Lyme and in a startup of acute phase Lyme, basically follow the instructions on the Lyme course.
You would consider getting a doctor locally where you could get a prescription of antibiotics in a chronic phase of antibiotics could help somewhat as well, but we really need to start getting your immune system to try to help kill this.
That's where a rife can be beneficial and then phase three if you're in an autoimmune phase that's a whole different follow-ups, whole different way you have to treat it because you're basically at that point bandaging it, treating it.
So follow everything that's on that on the Lyme course. If you're on that Lyme course, if you're not on the Lyme course, you really want to join the Lyme course because it gets tricky.
I will have the autoimmune course done with a matter of time here to that will help as well.
But people make major mistakes when they're treating chronic Lyme if they are in an autoimmune phase that can give them a lot of symptoms that they call herxybar reaction symptoms.
But any time they're not even herxybar reaction symptoms, it's that you're getting damage to self-tissue if you have self-antibodies back to that autoimmune question.
If you have self-antibodies to self-tissue and you're giving a lot of immune stimulants and you're at a TH1 dominant condition, you could actually be making yourself worse and helping your immune system kill your body.
So you do want to investigate if you've been, especially if you've experienced worse symptoms trying to take immune stimulants.
And it all goes against contrary thought. It's contrary to your typical thought that I have a biotox that I want to kill it.
So I'm going to take all these immune stimulants to kill it, but I feel worse. Maybe it's just die off.
Maybe, but more than likely if this is happening a lot if you're not getting any better.
If you have, if you have antibodies to self-tissue and you're stimulating the immune response, and you're at a TH1 dominant, it's already, you will, you know, fire or you will kill that once you have antibodies against first, which is the self-tissue.
And you can make yourself worse because you're just damaging yourself.
So you don't want to, you have to back off on those immune stimulants and you have to try to deal with this another way and calm down that inflammatory response, stimulate on what are called tea regulating ourselves, which helps balance the immune system.
And if you're still have an active antigen or active pathogen, you want to do things to kill it that won't be using your immune system and that's where the right question for the mental health.
I had a Syrex 10 test done.
How do I know what to do with it? So looking at that question, I pulled up the Syrex 10 test.
What a person would look at. This is just page one of the four by pages that come with the Syrex test 10 test.
So the Syrex array 10 test is a food immune antibody screen. So it's testing antibodies to different.
Epitides of proteins of different foods, cooked foods, raw foods, and measuring whether you have antibodies to it.
So this is page one of your tests. You have a really bad problem.
That is quite damaged. So greed would be normal. So if, let's say this top thing, it says egg white cooked.
You are in the equivocal range. That means to yellow is bad. Red is really bad. Let's use layman's terms here. Go it's milk really bad soft cheese plus hard cheese really bad yogurt.
I mean, do we have anything in the good range here on death thing? So this is a person who, who is got a lot of immune issues, a lot of immune compromise.
There is literally nothing on this page that they can eat.
This would be odd. There's a lot of people that would do this test that everything on all the pages is great. And they might have significant health issues. Well, they don't have food antibodies.
So that that is not the piece that we need to work on. But this is not an uncommon test for somebody with a lot of labor with any other autoimmune disease that they, they may even think that they have no food sensitivity.
They may think that, yeah, I am a gut. You know, that's strongest steel. I don't have any issues whatsoever. But yet, you look at that antibodies against it. So this means literally, every time this person would eat goat's milk, they fire this inflammatory response that's very high.
That's causing a lot of inflammation in the gut and inflammation in the gut is going to damage the epithelial lighting of the gut inflammation of the gut is going to cause inflammation in the brain and systemic inflammation.
And if there already is damage to the lighting of the gut, which definitely there is looking at this panel right here.
These antibodies can get across the damage got well into the blood causing an immune reaction to that peptide in the blood causing systemic inflammation.
This in itself food antibodies to different foods and you're eating those foods. If you have anybody's to different foods and you're eating those foods, that can be a primary source of systemic eating whole body inflammation.
And you can't get better, the better, how many supplements you take, the better, how many tools you are using, the better, how many good things you're doing. If you're causing this literal, you know, house fire, every time you eat that thing, you're not going to get better.
So this Syrix testing to me is really important with any person that is any health compromise because it really helps you understand what you could be doing to damage your body that you might not even have symptoms.
The person might not have gut pain at all kind of on this prop person probably does, but let's say the person everything was in green, but just these things, the peas, the pea protein, and the popcorn was in red in this, let's say everything else was in the green.
But let's say they eat popcorn three times a week, because it's just their family treat, and they don't notice any problems. They don't have any stomachache, but every time they eat popcorn, they cause this ramped up inflammation, this literal bonfire in their gut that is or in their bloodstream that is causing their health problems.
It can be causing the rheumatoid arthritis. It can be, it can be causing their Hashimoto's. It can be causing that there's something that they're attributing to their live disease or their, their MS, and they never put the two things together.
So I'm very big on doing this kind of testing because you can find things out that you could really, really help people with.
So you run that test and you go to six, I never had any stomachache, but I had popcorn. I had no idea. And this person then takes popcorn out of their diet. Let's pretend that, you know, they had popcorn pee, cooked peas and pea protein, and they were doing a pea protein shake every day too.
And they removed those things from their diet from a period of time, and their whole inflammatory process goes down. Now, I believe that this is just one facet in a person's health.
There's other things going on. Maybe they have biotoxids, maybe they have heavy metals, maybe they have, you know, live disease, maybe they have damaged blood brain barrier, maybe they have a damaged lung barrier, maybe they have mold issues too.
So you have to deal with as many of these facets as possible if you want to get better, and I know it gets exhausting.
But the problem that people have and the mistake that people make is they think that it's going to, they're just missing this one piece, and they do that one piece, and then they get really disappointed because they didn't see your results.
But they dropped everything else, and it's that's, that's an error. So if a person's got a test that looks like this example here, then you know they have a, you know, really bad damage barrier.
So they're got barrier needs to be healed. So just going off all these foods is not going to fix their problem. They need to be doing stuff to heal their gut at the same time.
And that is just absolutely essential. But again, it's not the only thing. If they have a damaged gut barrier, they probably have a damaged blood brain barrier.
They probably have a damaged comular barrier in the lungs, and those things need to be healed too. So you have to do a lot of things concurrently to really see the benefit.
And it takes time for your body to heal, and you want to do a retest after a period of time to see those changes. So I do have a video on the different arrays that will help you in array 10.
And it goes into more detail that I'm talking about in this, but I think this will give you a nice overview.
And of course, we give God the glory to all things we know that he is our healer and we trust him and give him, just, you know, understand that he gets the glory even in our sickness. There's a purpose for that too.
And we want to see that purpose and glorify him and all those.
All right, thank you for today's holistic health hour. And we will be back next time.